Pues así es es Francia la que se ha
clasificado con un partido de tres goles
por uno ante Polonia un muy buen partido
de los franceses que empezaron sufriendo
un poco porque este equipo salió
bastante bien ha parado al campo de
juego tratando sobre todo de frenar
todos los ataques por la banda izquierda
allí justamente donde está kilian mbappé
sin embargo la apertura del marcador
estuvo a cargo de riego quien recibió
finalmente un pase de mbappé esto ya fue
sobre el final del primer tiempo y luego
ya en el segundo Francia supo quedarse
aún más con el control de la pelota y
vendría Entonces el primer gol de mbappé
en este partido ya para el minuto 77 en
una muy buena jugada colectiva que salió
desde un despegue de
nacido Pues el el hacedor de juego en
este equipo luego de allí un pase que
controla muy bien
sirve a mbappé para que cruces la pelota
y entre en portería polaca y ya el
tercero vendría sobre los últimos
instantes 91 también de mbappé un pase
de Marcus durama y al final ya sobre los
últimos instantes hubo una penalti a
favor de Polonia por una mano de
upamecano en el área y finalmente Pues
fue lewandowski quien logró descontar y
con este resultado tres goles por uno
pues Francia se clasifica y además de
esto pues kilian mbappé ya suma cinco
goles en este mundial y por ahora es el
goleador de este torneo y Natalia que se
espera de este segundo partido que
enfrentará a Inglaterra con senegal Cuál
es la expectación allá en Qatar
Bueno pues es un partido que se espera
bastante apretado porque senegal ha
venido dando sorpresa ha venido
creciendo a lo largo de su participación
en este mundial Pero bueno tiene
enfrente a Inglaterra Inglaterra que
comenzó con una goleada seis goles por
dos ante Irán Inglaterra que además pues
se tiene a Harry kane quien dice está
listo para poder comenzar a marcar goles
porque es digamos de las figuras
inglesas la que por ahora no ha marcado
y recordemos que hace cuatro años Pues
él fue el goleador de ese mundial en
Rusia en 2018 Así que veremos qué ocurre
en ese estadio esa esta noche para saber
Pues cuál quién de senegal o de
Inglaterra va a enfrentarse a Francia En
los cuartos de final